Oh
thank you so much you know it's hard to
believe that it has been eight years
since I first came to this convention to
talk with you about why I thought my
husband should be President remember how
I told you about his character and
conviction his decency and His grace the
traits that we've seen every day that he
served our country in the White House I
also told you about our daughters how
they are the heart of our hearts the
center of our world and during our time
in the White House we'd have the joy of
watching them grow from bubbly little
girls into poised young women a journey
that started soon after we arrived in
Washington when they set off for their
first day at their new school I will
never forget that winter morning as I
watched our girls just 7 and 10 years
old pile into those black SUVs with all
those big men with guns and I saw their
little faces pressed up against the
window and the only thing I could think
was what have we done
see because at that moment I realized
that our time in the White House would
form the foundation for who they would
become and how well we managed this
experience could truly make or break
them that is what Barack and I think
about every day as we try to guide and
protect our girls through the challenges
of this unusual life in the spotlight
how we urge them to ignore those who
question their fathers citizenship or
fake
how we insist that the hateful language
they hear from public figures on TV does
not represent the true spirit of this
country how we explain that when someone
is cruel or acts like a bully you don't
stoop to their level no our motto is
when they go low we go high
with every word we utter with every
action we take we know our kids are
watching us we as parents are their most
important role models and let me tell
you Barack and I take that same approach
to our jobs as President and First Lady
because we know that our words and
actions matter not just to our girls but
the children across this country kids
kids who tell us I saw you on TV I wrote
a report on you for school kids like the
little black boy who looked up at my
husband his eyes wide with hope and he
wondered is my hair like yours and make
no mistake about it this November when
we go to the polls that is what we're
deciding not democrat or republican not
left or right now in this election and
every election is about who will have
the power to shape our children for the
next four or eight years of their lives
and I
I am here tonight because in this
election there is only one person who i
trust with that responsibility only one
person who i believe is truly qualified
to be President of the United States and
that is our friend Hillary Clinton
see
I trust I trust Hillary to lead this
country because I've seen her lifelong
devotion to our nation's children not
just her own daughter who she has raised
to perfection but but every child who
needs a champion kids who take the long
way to school to avoid the gangs kids
who wonder how they'll ever afford
college kids whose parents don't speak a
word of English but dream of a better
life kids who look to us to determine
who and what they can be you see Hillary
has spent decades doing the relentless
thankless work to actually make a
difference in their lives
advocating for kids with disabilities as
a young lawyer fighting for children's
healthcare as first lady and for quality
child care in the Senate and when she
didn't win the nomination eight years
ago she didn't get angry or
disillusioned
she Hillary did not Hillary did not pack
up and go home because as a true public
servant Hilary knows that this is so
much bigger than her own desires and
disappointments
so she proudly stepped up to serve our
country once again as Secretary of State
traveling the globe to keep our kids
safe and look there were plenty of
moments when Hillary could have decided
that this work was too hard that the
price of public service was too high
that she was tired of being picked apart
for how she looks or how she talks or
even how she laughs but here's the thing
what I admire most about Hillary is that
she never buckles under pressure she she
never takes the easy way out and Hillary
Clinton has never quit on anything in
her life
and when I think about the kind of
president that I want for my girls and
all our children that's what I want I
want someone with the proven strength to
persevere someone who knows this job and
takes it seriously someone who
understands that the issues of president
faces are not black and white and cannot
be boiled down to 140 characters look
because
because when when you have the nuclear
codes at your fingertips and the
military in your command you can't make
snap decisions you can't have a thin
skin or a tendency to lash out you need
to be steady and measured and
well-informed
I want a president with a record of
public service someone whose life's work
shows our children that we don't chase
fame and fortune for ourselves we fight
to give everyone a chance to succeed and
and we give back even when we're
struggling ourselves because we know
that there is always some worth one more
soft and there but for the grace of God
go I I want a president who will teach
our children that everyone in this
country matters a president who truly
believes in the vision that our founders
put forth all those years ago that we
are all created equal each of a loved
part of the great American story and
when crisis hits we don't turn against
each other no we listen to each other we
lean on each other because we are always
stronger together
and I am here tonight because I know
that that is the kind of president that
Hillary Clinton will be and that's why
in this election I'm with her
you see Hillary understands that the
president is about one thing and one
thing only it's about leaving something
better for our kids that's how we've
always moved this country forward by all
of us coming together on behalf of our
children folks who volunteer to coach
that team to teach that Sunday School
class because they know it takes a
village heroes of every color and Creed
who wear the uniform and risked their
lives to keep passing down those
blessings of liberty police officers and
the protesters in Dallas who all
desperately want to keep our children
safe people who lined up in Orlando to
donate blood because it could have been
their son their daughter in that club
leaders like Tim Kaine
who show who show our kids what decency
and devotion look like leaders like
Hillary Clinton who has the guts and the
grace to keep coming back and putting
those cracks in that highest and hardest
glass ceiling and so she finally breaks
through lifting all of us along with her
that is the story of this country the
story that has brought me to the stage
tonight the story of generations of
people who felt the lash of bondage the
shame of servitude the sting of
segregation but who kept on striving and
hoping and doing what needed to be done
so that's a day I wake up every morning
in a house that was built by slaves
and and I watch my daughter's two
beautiful intelligent black young women
playing with their dogs on the White
House lawn
mb and because of Hillary Clinton my
daughters and all our sons and daughters
now take for granted that a woman can be
President of the United States
so don't let anyone ever tell you that
this country isn't great that somehow we
need to make it great again because this
right now is the greatest country on
earth
and as my my daughter's prepare to set
out into the world I want a leader who
is worthy of that truth a leader who is
worthy of my girls promise and all our
kids promise a leader who will be guided
every day by the love and hope and
impossibly big dreams that we all have
for our children so in this election we
cannot sit back and hope that everything
works out for the best we cannot afford
to be tired or frustrated or cynical now
hear me between now and November we need
to do what we did eight years ago and
four years ago
we need some knock on every door we need
to get out every vote we need to pour
every last ounce of our passion and our
strength and our love for this country
into a lectin Hillary Clinton as
president of the United States of
America
so let's get to work thank you all